c'est qui lui alors marc et d'une vous
étiez demain tu es roncq nom est devenu
votre humour de merde commence à casser
les couilles non c'est pas d'humour j
avoue les drones j'aurais fait autre
chose j'aurais fait bonjour madame je
vais vous prendre ce petit pas ou
alors comment le définir l humour du
flambeau alors pour avoir beaucoup je la
prenais les écritures c'est extrêmement
dur et à définir et à écrire je suis
derrière toi
ajoute antoine
humour d'accus en amérique chez les dida
pato ou dans un humour un peu anglais
que je peux voir face sinon je vois
rarement sans en
consommer l'eau c'est très monty python
c'est et en même temps
je pense ça peut lui faire plaisir que
je dit ça ya un peu des nuls aussi
pourquoi tony sans jambes et avoir du
mal a remporté quelques lambeaux alors
de tomber ou parce qu'en 2007 c'est un
unijambiste qui a gagné haut la main ou
la jambe si j'ose dire ça part dans tous
les sens sert tout est possible
j'allais dire le meilleur comme le pire
les moi j'adore le pire annick ce qu'il
a dit sur les pailles il a dit tu les
prends tu vois comme ça tu les roule
comme ça aux formes de didgeridoo et tu
t'es fou dans le culte charolles
de génial c'est que je crois que les
auteurs enfin je laisse antilles ne se
sont absolument pas censuré à qui
profite le crime à la famille juive non
alors laissez la en dehors de pouce à
nos censure de toute façon canal pour le
coup ils sont vraiment nos potes là
dessus c'est qu'ils sont un peu nos
censure avec nous ou fensch baisse de
dos c'est ça nous et le mont ventoux
mais ça s'est effrité le temps que tu
viens ici ça me plait l'idée que ce soit
très border quoi vraiment patent
challans pour on aborde tous les sujets
ça c'est assez fou quand même j'ai
l'impression que à part sur internet sur
youtube on n'a plus trop ça à la
télévision le
chimique oui j'espère que ça ne sera pas
la famine normalement non cette liberté
d'écriture liberté de ton nullité
d'interprétation c'est assez assez
jouissif
[Musique]
pour fort j'ai envie de boire l'anneau
piña colada
bienvenue de me balader la vie roanne à
aider tout un clochard comme ça
gratuitement et de la foulée de
guacamole pas fait comme on a pu miata
c'est une très bonne farine il ya encore
de la place
aujourd'hui pour des séries loufoque
dingue
là bas
on
s'inspire d'un truc d' aventure pour en
faire une vraie série au final et c'est
ça qui compte parce que c'est ça qu'on a
besoin d'avoir dans le panorama
française cd série de comédie a
franchement je vois pas ce qui pourrait
gâcher mon bonheur
coquine donc ça donne un humour qui est
hyper race est hyper particulier
qui est très compliqué à définir sans
penser au personnage de marc lui-même
personne même
il marque est un enfant dans une peau
d'adultes
j'en attends
c'est une des personnes qui me fait le
plus rire donc on fait quoi voir venir
aux mains bah si tu veux ya aucun
problème est ce qu'il ya un truc quand
ils jouent marque il en est quand il
joue le roi des cons balade les deux
quoi là qu'est ce qui se passe mais il
juge par marc ira mon cou non c'est lui
qui dit que l'aventuré a commencé à bien
ou tard qu'elle commence maintenant et b
tu l'entends parler oui je l'entends
parler il a raison et puis j'ai un vrai
respect pour son travail cinq bosseur
jonathan sera vrai bosseur pas facile
tous les jours avec les gangs fabien
gros qu on est obligé de vous dire ça
mais bon heureusement je suis là qui
fait la richesse du truc c'est qu'il ya
effectivement des moments qui sont très
très d absurde dans l'avion saison une
avec un aspect une sorte de comique de
répétition qui est poussé à l'outrance
et moi je suis très client ça lui c'est
william voilà vous n'êtes pas william
est ce que ces toiles en jute une
harmonie c'est tony ça je le savais mais
lui sait qui sait où les yankees et
william c'est lui billy billy billy il
ne s'appelle pas billy alors il
s'appelle comment oui c'est williams et
pat williams dans l'eau mais qui
williams devient sous sinon oui j'ai un
souci c'est que je ne sais pas qui est
william voilà des trucs sont plus dans
le dialogue et dans la van nhon
cohabitation il ya le mot [ __ ] à ça je
plaisante et un truc sont hyper
agressive très caca pipi assumer moi
j'adore ça aussi
ça c'est une bonne chose
on a tourné une scène de touristes à
general terre que tous les personnages
étaient atteindre ce qu'on appelle un
beau ventre qui provoque une purée de
fès pour rester un peu enfantin aucun
doute c'est la triste et je peux rien
pour vous désolé
je crois que je m'attends cohen est très
porté sur cet humour régressif
le texte est assez simple c'est plutôt à
base de tomates op donc on peut varier
les prises les axes c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est la purée de face mais
donc c'est très très agréable finalement
de de se retrouver à voir ça à faire
comme comédien si c'est quand il m'a
quitté d'efforts à distribuer les cartes
tue pas le distribuer du pq plutôt
basses très drôle très solides en terme
d'écriture mais qui n'hésite pas à
casser quand il trouve que c'est pas ses
fruits quand c'est quand ils trouvent
que c'est trop écrit pour amener des
présents du réel la cache à oublions
l'ouïe fine alors je crois que j'ai
quelque chose pour redistribuer les
cartes ne pas distribuer plus tôt du pq
et après on pas s'assumer cas ok la
marche pas trop jeune
je crois que j'ai une petite idée pour
distribuer des cartes apprentissage au
départ c'est de se laisser complètement
faire en essayant de lâcher prise et
voilà mais quand on a confiance en me
donc ya pas de raison de ne pas lâcher
prise vous êtes vraiment de gros cons
en 40 ans personne n'a jamais parlé
comme ça mais moi je te parle pas mais
bravo fait partie d'un cercle très fermé
de ceux qui me parle il ya une structure
et une colonne vertébrale mais c'est
ouvert 1 voilà s'est ouvert ce qui est
bon à prendre il prend quand j'ai envie
d'être attaché au fond d'une cave il
qu'on tape avec une règle sur les fesses
alors je vais faire une sorte
je dois faire quand mes enfants me
manque c'est qu'il va pleuvoir beaucoup
et c'est sûr que ces femmes de 2,2 du
suivi exactement ce qui se passe sur le
plateau donc ils sont un éveil de toutes
les propositions la blague first la
blague passera avant tout c'est que même
si on a du texte bien on est pressé dans
le temps il ya une bonne à pro qui sort
top on refait cette blague là donc ça
nous encourage à sortir des blagues
alors moi quand j'ai envie d'être
attaché au fond d'une cave et converse
de la cire chaude sur les fesses c'est
qu'il va pleuvoir et en fait on refait
ça et tout le monde va dire c'est qu'il
va pleuvoir tout le monde avec le truc à
moi c'est qu'il va pleuvoir allez c'est
parti quand tu tournes ils t'envoient
des blagues en même temps qu'ils te
disent ok 10 à 10 a dit ça
jamais je m'abonne jamais où ça s'arrête
jamais vraiment non tu rêves dans le jeu
et en plus on envoie des vannes en même
temps ça nourrit et tu peux ensuite
après rebondir
c'est toi qui prends pour moi bien dosé
doivent y travailler pour moi j'avais
serait pour toi jamais travaillé pour
toi je te tutoie un jour donc il y avait
une espèce de richesse comme ça ça
ferait tourner comme ça pendant des
heures ça ça débite est à mes fesses aux
mêmes dans l'édition gauche est propre
et moi avec mon cul gourcuf vélo entre
les pâtes riz paddy à alès mon école on
va t'en démission je les ai jamais vu
annuler l'épreuve
même dans l'édition gaucher contre
droitier quand les gauchers avaient
perdu leurs seins alors si l'on spéciaux
mon plan cul refait mon cul mots qu à la
fin et c'est avec deux moteurs cas les
démons que non que mon coeur fessard
fais ça tu vois en coupe patronne oui et
on dirige à l'intérieur ok monture
laisse tomber garde en vingt ans des
missions je les ai jamais vu annuler
l'épreuve aramon
même dans l'édition cochet contre
droitier quand les gosses y avaient
perdu leurs six solutions
on a on s'est toujours permis de faire
des impros et parce que c'est aussi ça
le sel de notre série j'aime ça et je
sais que c'est un moyen de créer des
cadres et à la recherche à la pépite moi
je vais à la recherche à la pépite donc
quand je dirige les gens c'est pareil on
ne refait 5 10 15 tant qu'on n'a pas la
pépite en tout cas j'essaye parce que
parfois on la trouve pas et la pépite
avec jalard vrai il n'ya pas besoin mais
j'essaye toujours quand je dirige les
gens de les amener à ça c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est d'aller chercher le
truc pas prévu il ya plein de choses qui
sont sortis de ça dans cette saison soit
le trio des marques c'est en cherchant
c'est en laissant faire nous on cherche
encore tu vois qu'on a trouvé des
petites pépites de faire toutes les
choses à 3
[Applaudissements]
quant à elle au kart'are au chômage
qui a connu la boule ondulé mais c'est
fini non non non non non non
[Applaudissements]
ça arrive comme ça en fait ça peut pas
arriver quand tu dis seulement texte
c'est impossible de trouver cette magie
là je vous propose un adversaire d'un
autre calibre quévert incroyable et
l'incroyable le jury ce qui est marrant
c'est que avec pierre on s'est dit
autant à saison une scène ont tâtonné un
peu avant de partir en couille là c'est
parti en couille immédiatement certes
y'a pas un truc qu'on a fait normalement
tout de suite c'est tout de suite parti
en couille vous savez ce que ça veut
dire modérée la en italien non c'est pas
ça veut dire négativité alors découpé
moi toute cette négativité vous lui
dites au revoir négativité à les hits
comme l'a fait un peu plus de niro
les moments de récréation s'aimantent
création pure il faut avoir ce ce qui
faisait aller on ne sait pas où tu vois
une tirer le fil d un truc que j'ai ri
pierre est bien avec moins de suez
donc oui c'est la grande récré où
j'entends rien vous voulez rencontrer
non vous voulez le rencontrer non on
veut pas qui veut le rencontrer ne sont
pas alors vous ne sautez pas non non non
je ne saute pas top marques qu'est ce
que vous faites là je sais pas vous me
faites penser moi
[Musique]